there is always this pretty large and
sometimes contentious sort of idea about
what should be restricted what do you
consider competitive what do you
consider anti-competitive and how does
all that work but restricting game
content actually takes the game and sort
of pushes it further away from how the
vast majority of people actually play
the game where they play with everything
so it's on us as developers to properly
balance the game for sure it's on all of
us who are interested in eSports to
promote a real healthy ecosystem where
the public game and the competitive game
can be as similar to one another as
possible that why right here right now
on this show tonight we are going to
demonstrate the bands and protect system
so when you're playing in a competitive
gaming arena or in a custom game there's
an entire meta game where players take
turns deciding what piece of content
they want to ban and what piece of
content they want to protect so before
the game even starts players are
presented with a series of choices each
player votes to ban or protect one piece
of game content now this is a very
flexible system with a lot of custom
configuration now for the purposes of
demonstration we put all of the game
content in the system that's anything in
create a class that's all the score
streaks that's every specialist weapon
or ability that's hundreds of pieces of
game content so it's a whole new metal
layer for the game one that the players
are in complete control of this has the
added benefit of truly demystifying that
behind the scenes negotiation between
players and leagues and divest that you
were talking about now the players will
decide and those decisions will change
moment to moment game the game and
opponent to opponent yeah well it's kind
of interesting as you mentioned
specialist which of course are new to
black ops 3 they introduced a complete
new class of weapons and abilities game
which can really
shave a match you know how do they fit
into the competitive environment as
we've talked about before we like to say
that the specialist weapons and
abilities are designed to fit in that
power band that exists between all the
content and create a class and the
scores drinks themselves so it's
absolutely true that specialist weapons
and abilities are going to be extremely
effective and very very powerful in a
competitive game situation so as an
example there is nothing quite like
finding yourself in the right situation
were to 'not e to activate ruins
overdrive for a clutch run with the
satellite drone slam-dunking it right in
for a game-winning score now this makes
picking the right specialist or ability
and right time for the right game mode
all that much more critical to the game
so specialists work with the competitive
agenda and a very important way that we
call the specialist draft now the
specialist draft is when each player
from each side can only have one
specialist weapon or ability / team so
let me use an example let's say it's a
program it's four on four it's uplink
during the setup of that game only one
player can take rural and overdrive the
other three players on that team have to
take a different weapon from the
specialist or a different specialist
ability yeah I mean it seems like the
teams have to think very very carefully
about what they pick and but more
importantly I think you know from a kind
of contrasting perspective I think
there's a lot more to discuss in terms
of the metagame and doing that analysis
which begs a really important question
which is what maven and mr. X have to
say about it so what are your guys his
thoughts all right this is amazing you
know man you were a former professional
FPS player I was semi-professional at
best but hear stuff like meta balance
now it's all these words just man I'm
getting so pumped or just think of the
way this is gonna defer safai making
such more dynamic and you get deeper
into the band gap attacks right you know
a team that has a player like clay sir
probably has to protect his dominant AR
they absolutely really good with where
he has to get good with all the a or so
it adds so much more depth to the game
than the way the specialist to use you
know a player like TP maybe he goes for
a more obj mind and specialist and then
know some of the best players in the
game they'll pick some of the weapon
specialist and be able to use those to
their advantage
so the game will change game to game
opponent to opponent well we saw just in
the course of yesterday really right now
one player is going off big time with
this specific rifle next thing you know
that gets banned next map the course of
you know any sports season the course of
the game the way it'll watch this stuff
change is going to be absolutely amazing
but you know we talked about the fact
that we have competitive players here we
are of course going to be having some
black ops 3 action we've got Scott main
stage we're going to have a live draft
you